une lune comme sanctuaire arbitraire là-bas je me
rends compte que j'écris comme X aussi sur ma Megan
dans mon pays d'échanges K je suis
un creuseur
de fossés en ce qui concerne la drogue dans schlotz Co c'est
plutôt bien nous sommes le rebond vert et
nous avons le rêve américain je trouve  bon travail
en effet de pointe Sarah je fais ce vœu 100
ans ou famille tout a changé
[Musique]
ça fait 100 ans la saumure de cornichon
l'a parfaitement conservé à l'ancienne musique
le monde a changé tout le monde je sais c'est de l'
or tu as pu traquer les
grands  -petit-fils où sont-ils ils
sont décédés c'était un accident de voiture il
me dira tout de leur mort comment
leurs corps sont morts leurs visages comme une vie
laissée nous nous lierons à notre douleur
je comprends pourquoi tu es une
personne religieuse mais je ne sais pas comment  est-ce que tu pleures la
mort les parents font bien l'idée est que
toute l'affaire est une idée très stupide
tu n'as pas de femme pas de travail pas d'amis pas de
travail dont tu as besoin Je vais bien
ça deviendra le succès Wow très piquant
hmm ouais c'est tout droit du diable
toi  va enfin  faites revenir leurs parents
ne parlez pas de mes parents vous ne les avez jamais
rencontrés le cœur du monde entier
Je ne suis probablement pas le meilleur scénario pour
la famille est devenue une vieille entreprise que nous
avons vue Je suis sûr que cela vieillit bien si l'
homme  ne jette pas de poncho c'est parce que
ces hommes mettent secrètement le ou ne font pas
quelque chose de mal il a guéri la poliomyélite argile rouge
bio Jonas Salk vous a donné
il a mangé ça son père non comme David
Bowie
donne moi une mère non c'est aussi David
Bowie tout ça  affiches David Bowie
[Musique]
toi